Some have called it the mother of all battles
and some argue that its television coverage
changed the face of war.
It's hard to get everyone to agree when it
comes to the first Gulf War.
The media attention for Saddam Hussein dates
back to August 2, 1990, when the ra s ordered
his troops to invade neighboring Kuwait, a
small emirate of only eighteen thousand square
km, with 4.5 million inhabitants largely living
in the capital Al Kuwait, but very rich in
oil fields.
War broke out on the night of January 16-17,
1991, after a series of ultimatums from the
United Nations asking for the withdrawal of
Iraqi forces from Kuwait.
However, a conflict that didn't last long,
6 weeks, just long enough for a coalition
of 34 countries led by the United States to
showcase its overwhelming superiority by deploying
over five hundred thousand troops and forcing
the Iraqi leader to surrender the following
February 28.
It was an intense few weeks, however, and
the relentless news coverage ended up making
the first Gulf War a real media event.
In particular, it was always in the spotlight
of CNN, an all news channel established just
over 10 years earlier, which imposed itself
on the eyes of the world by providing continuous
news coverage of the progress of Operation
Desert Storm, the actual military action against
Iraq, preceded by Desert Shield, or the massive
deployment of troops to Saudi Arabia to contain
Iraqi ambitions.
Television coverage that influenced U.S. foreign
policy decisions to the point of affecting
the course of the conflict, according to what
has been called the "CNN effect."
Then we come back to it.
Before the fateful day of the invasion, no
one had been more concerned about the Iraqi
leader, even though he had been leading the
Bath regime (from the secular, socialist-inspired
Bath party) since 1979.
No one, in the context of numerous meetings
among top politicians in the Arab region held
on the eve of the invasion, guessed or wanted
to guess that Iraq would prove to be an important
player on the international stage and that
its dictator's policies would pose a threat
to the world order.
Certainly the crisis triggered by the invasion
of Kuwait can be regarded not only as one
of the major international crises of the postwar
period, but also as a unique event.
Indeed, it's the first major post-Cold War
crisis to be located outside the dimension
of East-West confrontation.
For the first time, a member of the United
Nations, Kuwait precisely, hadn't just been
invaded, but totally occupied and annexed
by another, causing hundreds of thousands
of displaced people, disruption of trade of
two major oil producers, and worldwide economic
uncertainty.
If we analyze the scale of this war in terms
of casualties, we find that it s far less
than that of the major wars after 1945 (think
of Korea with 4.3 million dead, Vietnam with
over 2 million, the Iran-Iraq war with over
six hundred thousand, or Lebanon with two
hundred fifty thousand), but from the point
of view of mobilization and armaments used,
this was, after Korea, the largest interstate
conflict since World War II.
Militarily, we can identify three distinctive
features of it: the first is the extreme asymmetry
of casualties, facilitated by the rise of
new technologies: tens of thousands of casualties
on the Iraqi side, a few hundred on the coalition
side.
The second is the peculiar way the conflict
ended: with a sudden call for a halt by George
Bush senior, at a time when he could have
annihilated Saddam altogether.
The third and maybe most dramatic is the ecological
disaster that came with it, following the
Iraqi decision to set fire to Kuwait's oil
fields during the retreat.
You remember the famous scene from the movie
"Jarhead," don't you?
- INSERT CLIP - Of course it was not the first
time that war and ecological destruction went
hand in hand but in this case the destructive
action found no military justification and
was devastating to the healthiness of the
air over a large area of West Asia.
But exactly when did the hostilities date
back to?
The fateful August 2, 1990, is only the culmination
of a process rooted in September 1980, when
war operations between Iraq and Iran began,
resulting in a conflict that cost more than
half a million dead and ended with neither
winners nor losers but a cease-fire requested
by Tehran on August 8, 1988.
Of this conflict the American public (but
not the government and secret service of course)
knew almost nothing, just as it was barely
aware of the geopolitical rise of Saddam Hussein's
Iraq.
A military power, to be exact the fourth largest
in the world by number of armed forces, after
the USSR, China and the United States: 55
divisions, 1 mln trained men, five hundred
thousand aircrafts and five thousand five
hundred tanks.
But it was a power with disastrous public
finances, with an accumulated debt of one
hudnred billion dollars in 1988, due to the
government's huge military expenses during
the 8 years of bloody war.
A debt that couldn't be repaired even by attempting
to promote the private sector and domestic
agriculture.
But Saddam was convinced that the economy
would recover, believing he could count on
the support of oil lords Kuwait, Saudi Arabia
and the United Arab Emirates.
In fact, the 3 countries, along with the United
States and Israel, had supported in various
forms the Iraq-Iran War of the late 1980s
to contain Shiite fundamentalism provoked
by the Khomeini revolution, and Saddam expected
them to honor their debt of gratitude, for
benefiting from "Iraq's protective shield
against the Iranian threat."
In response there was a rush to drain the
oil fields and the release of large quantities
of oil onto the market, causing its price
to plummet (from $18 to $13 a barrel).
But the initiative taken by Kuwait was the
straw that broke the camel's back.
You should know that since the 1930s Iraq
had repeatedly claimed sovereignty over Kuwait,
on some occasions, denying its legitimacy
as a separate state, on others, questioning
the boundary delimitation between the two
countries, because the way the United Kingdom
had drawn its border back in 1923 prevented
Iraq from controlling a proper outlet to the
Persian Gulf, corresponding to the disputed
Bubiyan and Warbah islands and a piece of
desert where the Rumaila deposit is located,
crossing the border between the two states
and always claimed by Iraq.
We said, in the aftermath of the cease-fire
demanded by Tehran, Kuwait, contravening the
extraction quota agreements established at
OPEC (Organization of the Petroleum Exporting
Countries) increased crude oil extraction
from the Rumaila fields.
This episode, known as "oil theft through
Slant drilling," which is a particular extraction
technique using non-vertical drills, brought
more than $2.4 billion into the country's
treasury, corresponding to about three hundred
thousand barrels of oil per day.
An action that collapsed Baghdad's revenue,
which was 90 percent dependent on crude oil,
by about $7 billion a year, while interest
on the debt also amounted to $7 billion.
In fact, none of the Gulf countries came to
Saddam's aid by proposing to negotiate less
onerous forms of debt repayment, despite the
ra s' constant requests to ease the pressure.
So the invasion of Kuwait would offer a multi-layered
solution: a distraction from domestic discontent
over economic mismanagement, the possibility
of acquiring Kuwaiti assets and investments,
and the seizure of the oil fields themselves,
which was equivalent to controlling about
one-fifth of all world oil.
Saddam's hostility found confirmation on an
important occasion: at the Arab League meeting
held on July 16, 1990, Iraqi Foreign Minister
Tarek Aziz delivered to the League's secretary-general,
Shadli Klibi, a memorandum in the shape of
a declaration of war, accusing Kuwait of stealing
oil and the remaining Gulf countries of plotting
an economic conspiracy against Iraq aimed
at putting it out of business once and for
all.
We can say that the Iraqi dictator, already
supported in the past by the West, was convinced
that his move would have no practical consequences,
apart from the usual ritual protests.
This is confirmed by the July 25, 1990 summons
of U.S. Ambassador April Glaspie.
Saddam gave her barely an hour's notice, Glaspie
didn t make it in time to ask the State Department
for instructions, and the dialogue between
the two resolved into a comedy of misunderstandings:
too absorbed in the problems of the East,
the diplomat implied that the U.S. didn't
want to intrude on inter-Arab disputes.
The Iraqi dictator, convinced that he had
made his intentions clear, believed he had
obtained a tacit U.S. "green light" to invade
Kuwait.
An enormous mistake that would cost Iraq dearly,
which, from the time of the coalition ground
attack dated Feb. 24, 1991, lost control of
Kuwait in just four days.
Very controversial were the U.S. airstrikes
on the night of Feb. 26-27, directed against
Iraqi forces retreating from Al Kuwait to
the city of Basra.
The allies initially bombed the head and tail
of the huge column of vehicles traveling on
the so-called "highway of death," so as to
block the convoy and make it a static target
for subsequent attacks.
Some commentators suggested that the use of
force had been disproportionate, since the
Iraqis had agreed to withdraw, in compliance
with UN Resolution 660, and the column included
Kuwaiti prisoners, politicians and Palestinian
civilian refugees.
In any case, Saddam remained in power, cracking
down hard on Kurdish uprisings in the north
and Shiite uprisings in the south but had
to accept UN Resolution, pledging to destroy
his arsenals of unconventional weapons, pay
reparations for war damage, and abide by two
security zones created by the coalition, for
Kurds and Shiites precisely.
The allied victory, though described by almost
all the Western press as challenging but fair,
with Saddam Hussein compared to Adolf Hitler
and his "fearsome" army to the wehrmacht,
was easy and with very few casualties.
The whole thing, as we shall see, was peppered
with a campaign of mystification in the Western
press to justify the military intervention
and a spectacular live broadcast by journalist
Peter Arnett from Baghdad's Rashid Hotel describing
the bombing for hours; it was the first time
it happened on live television, and many,
including the Italian historian Antonio Scurati,
say that this contributed to the viewer's
lack of empathy for the war, who from then
on became accustomed to seeing death and bombs
on the screen not as a chilling loss of life
but as an effective distraction against boredom.
We said, the allied victory was easy, but
Bush was unable or maybe unwilling to take
advantage of the internal tensions in Iraqi
society to deal a decisive blow to Saddam.
It was felt that a tame but not ideologically
fundamentalist enemy could still come in handy
later, against possible unrest caused by peoples
bordering the Iraqis, apparently friendly
but actually hostile.
We mustn't forget, then, that a large section
of Islamic public opinion spoke out in favor
of Saddam himself, seeing the coalition's
presence as unwelcome Western interference
in Middle Eastern affairs and damage to the
holy sites of Islam.
Saddam, after having always been utterly secular
and completely indifferent to religion, knew
how to sniff the wind of protest and began
to pose as a protector of Islam, attending
public prayers and waving the rh toric of
faith.
His regime survived but internal rivalries
(Kurdish independence, Shiite (shiait) discontent)
were never quelled and came back to the surface
during the second Gulf War.
But that is another story.
Now is the time to talk about CNN effect,
but before we get there, let's see how American
and its allies' intervention in a conflict
that was taking place on the other side of
the world was justified.
The Bush administration tried to convince
world opinion that a real threat was imminent
and the Saudis that an American presence in
the Gulf was inevitable.
On August 15, 1990, it was George Bush Senior
himself who advanced the first rational explanation:
"Our jobs, our way of life, our freedom and
that of friendly countries around the world
would suffer if control of the world's great
oil reserves fell into the hands of that one
man, Saddam Hussein."
Reasons that seemed far-fetched.
There was no real threat to "freedom," except,
as historian Theodore Draper put it, "to that
freedom to drive your car on cheap fuel."
But interests in the Gulf area didn't stop
at oil.
Take for example the massive chemical arsenal
in the hands of Saddam Hussein.
Historical reconstructions show how Western
aid was instrumental in the development of
the Iraqi weapons program, mentioning more
than two thousand companies involved in various
ways in the formation of the Iraqi war industry.
GRAPHIC The list is as follows: 86 German-Federal
companies, 18 American, 18 British, 16 French,
12 Italian, 11 Swiss, 17 Austrian, 8 Belgian,
4 Spanish; and then Argentina (3 companies),
Japan (1 company), Brazil Egypt, Sweden, Holland,
Poland, India, Monaco, Jersey" (Quote taken
from Pierre Salinger, Eric Laurent, Gulf War.
The Secret Dossier, 1991, p.21).
Washington has long denied possessing information
regarding the chemical arsenal in the hands
of the ra s but recent studies prove otherwise.
On Aug. 23, 2013, Foreign Policy published
a survey showing, top secret documents in
hand, that the U.S. was aware of the existence
of these weapons as early as 1984 and was
constantly monitoring Saddam Hussein's plans
for a chemical attack on Iran, which would
have bent Tehran in 1988 through the use of
sarin gas and mustard gas.
The CIA had information that for decades remained
in the secret archives and about which the
government was always silent, even strongly
condemning the use of these instruments of
war, which, moreover, was prohibited by the
Geneva Protocol of 1925, ratified by the United
States in 1975.
Prior to that survey, it was known that the
U.S. had provided Iraq with intelligence support
and that there was only suspicion that the
chemical arsenal was being used in retaliation
for war.
More than suspicions, awareness: in fact,
some declassified documents extracted from
the National Archives in College Park, Maryland,
show how senior U.S. officials had been briefed
about the extent of the nerve gas attacks.
As journalist Shane Harris argued, this amounted
to a "tacit U.S. admission of complicity in
one of the most gruesome chemical weapons
attacks ever launched," in open contrast to
the Geneva Protocol already mentioned.
And what about diplomatic relations between
the United States and Iraq?
Well they were put at risk even before the
outbreak of the war.
On February 15, 1990, Voice of America-the
official radio and television service of the
U.S. government-broadcast a program appealing
to the public for a general mobilization against
authoritarian regimes around the world.
Iraq was mentioned almost constantly and Saddam
was portrayed as one of the worst expressions
of tyranny.
An apology came immediately from Washington,
but the matter was never digested by the Iraqi
leader.
An apology that Glaspie also made to him,
remember?
The American diplomat, for how he had been
portrayed in the interview conducted by Diane
Sawyer on ABC News, claiming that that was
the typical journalistic method used to discredit
any political figure.
But how far did the news media go?
The news outlets succeeded in legitimizing
the U.S. military intervention in the Gulf,
overnight transforming Saddam Hussein from
a friend of the West to the embodiment of
Adolf Hitler, endorsing George Bush senior's
line of thinking.
Think that the New York Times, in an editorial
published on August 9, 1990 stated that "President
Bush has drawn a line in the sand, committing
U.S forces to face down Saddam Hussein.
The costs and risks are enormous, but on balance,
he has made the right choice in the right
way."(New York Times.
August 9, 1990 edition).
Saddam had officially become a U.S. problem,
and the proof lies in the fact that in the
time span between August 2 and November 8,
1990, the Washington Post and the New York
Times began to cover Iraq, Saudi Arabia and
Kuwait constantly.
The former published a total of over one thousand
seven hundred articles on the subject (1742)
and the latter over two thousand four hundred
(2472), with a focus on news events, obviously
ignoring the real reasons for the conflict
and why U.S.-Iraq relations had worsened in
recent years.
In short, an apt comparison that resonated
with the people, "accepted by 6 out of 10
Americans," as reported in a poll conducted
between August 9 and 10, 1990 for the New
York Times.
For the television industry, on the other
hand, the Gulf War was more of a story of
American prowess, especially a celebration
of technological power.
It s estimated that 17 percent of the images
shown were shots of missiles and cutting-edge
war technology.
Consider that on January 22, 1991, CNN spoke
of the Patriot missiles as if they were human
actors ("Hailed as one of the first heroes
in the Gulf War, [the Patriot missiles] uses
quick thinking to outsmart the enemy" CNN.
Evening edition of January 22, 1991).
But it was also a glorification of the courage,
determination, and skill of American soldiers.
If with Vietnam, television had brought to
light the atrocities of war, something different
was happening with the Gulf: a narrative marked
by the opposition between good and evil was
adopted, packaged within a real show, complete
with custom logo and music to accompany the
reports.
A show expertly hosted by CNN.
The green light for Operation Desert Storm
came when New York was minutes away from 7
p.m. on Jan. 16, 1991, the news networks'
prime time.
On the first night of nonstop bombing, Americans
were addicted to the images of war and didn
t tear themselves away from the live broadcasts
on CNN.
This was because shortly after the attack
on Baghdad began, all the networks lost their
video link from Iraq.
The only broadcaster to maintain it with its
reporters was precisely CNN.
On the screens were the images of three journalists:
war correspondent Peter Arnett, reporter John
Holliman, and TV anchorman Bernard Shaw.
In fact, CNN in September 1990 had managed
to obtain permission from Iraqi officials
to install a "fourwire" satellite phone, a
device that could withstand signal loss.
On Jan. 17, all crews present in Baghdad,
including CNN's, were asked to leave the Rashid
Hotel -- headquarters of the international
press -- marked as a coalition bombing target
for the following night.
Holliman and Shaw decided to leave, while
Peter Arnett remained on site.
The Rashid hotel was never bombed, and for
the next two weeks, Arnett was the only U.S.
citizen broadcasting information and interviews
from Iraq, via the fourwire link carried on
a truck, with a large CNN initials visible
on the canopy, so that coalition planes wouldn't
mistake the vehicle for a scud missile shipment.
So by the end of the month CNN became the
only news provider for more than a hundred
countries, the primary source of information
from the Gulf.
To ensure that CNN, as an all news channel
could broadcast twentyfour seven news, two
military analysts were hired on a permanent
basis: former Air Force Major General Perry
McCoy Smith and military strategy expert James
Blackwell.
It was Major McCoy Smith in one of his books
who explained the formula for the American
broadcaster's success: "CNN had the reporters,
the satellite linkups, the engineers, the
producers, and expert commentators in place
or on standby.
It had a leadership team which understood,
before the war broke out, that this was going
to be a story of giant proportions."(Perry
McCoy Smith, How Cnn Fought the War: A View
from the Inside, 1991).
The job of the analysts was to always be at
the broadcaster's beck and call, always ready
to comment on the images, to explain the strategic
meaning of a certain bombing and the technical
details about reconnaissance planes and missiles
dropped on a variety of targets.
A rather simple example explains the power
of the media in influencing public opinion:
on January 23, 1991, barely a week into the
war, Major Smith during a broadcast recommended
reading 3 books to better understand the strategies
behind ongoing operations.
All three sold out by the same evening and
publishers rushed with reprinting.
One of the three titles - If War Comes, How
Defeat Saddam Hussein by Trevor Dupuy - boomed
in demand and forced the publishers to reprint
six hundred thousand copies.
However, the persuasive power of CNN effect
also affected foreign policy decisions: a
case study is from February 1991 and is related
to Kurdish refugees who had sought shelter
from Iraqi forces in the mountains southeast
of Turkey.
Media coverage of the Kurdish crisis was intensive,
emphasizing both the precarious conditions
in which the Kurds were living and the demand
that something be done to help them.
The images shocked the feelings of world leaders.
British Prime Minister John Major decided
to take the issue to the European community
and convinced first European partners and
then President Bush to create humanitarian
corridors in Iraq.
And so began what would become Operation Provide
Comfort, aimed at getting refugees from the
Gulf War to safety.
Barely a year after the conflict in the Middle
East and moving elsewhere, the United States
decided, under heavy media pressure, to intervene
in response to the humanitarian emergency
resulting from the Somali civil war.
But in October 1993 everything changed: images
of a U.S. soldier killed and dragged through
the streets of Mogadishu quickly went around
the world, prompting President Clinton to
withdraw troops from the territory.
John Shattuck, assistant secretary of state
between 1993 and 1998, reveals how the media
first brought the U.S. into Somalia and then
out of the conflict, according to a so-called
push and pull effect: "The media got us into
Somalia and then got us out" (John Shattuck,
From Massacres to Genocide: The Media, Public
Policy and Humanitarian Crises, 1996, p. 174).
But the ability of televison to determine
what rises to the status of an international
crisis finds express confirmation in a sentence
uttered by Bill Clinton on July 17, 1995,
in response to the media call for military
intervention in Bosnia: "We have a war by
CNN.
Our position is unsustainable, it's killing
the U.S. position of strength in the world"
(Bob Woodward, The Choice, 1996, p. 261).
Well, we have also come to the end today,
I thank you all for your attention and see
you in the next video.
Bye!